I need the real key some space oh my god
what
Adele just released a new song oh no I
remember the first time I heard someone
like you I cried for two hours Adele's
music is so relatable and sad Shh do you
hear that Oh
my god it's already happening and now
music it's too beautiful the song is
spreading all over the Internet
we've got to protect people from
reflecting on their past heartbreaks
yeah
this is for making me think about my
ex-boyfriend every time I hear rolling
in the deep' poof
hopefully nobody else here ah Mike you
gotta listen to this no way her music is
too emotional
good job now let's go stay some more
lives
wait sounds like someone's sobbing
thank you just dying oh sorry about that
huh all right
I'll rip off their headphones you go
over Mike we don't have time to stop
everyone from listening to Adele we got
to get out of here
katelyn wait why what's wrong we can't
run forever
Adele will never stop creating music
that makes us feel naked it's scarred
and empowered all at the same time
whether it's today tomorrow or next week
we're never been gonna hear her new song
so let's face it
Adele can't be stopped
and in other news the lack of rain in
Los Angeles is no longer a problem
thanks to all the tears created by
Adele's new songs